ناسا جاهزة أخيرًا لإطلاق صاروخها الضخم
Artemis one إلى القمر ، قام
مهندسو مركز كينيدي للفضاء باختبار
هذا الصاروخ لأشهر قبل أن
ينطلق في مهمته القمرية المخطط لها في
أواخر أغسطس ، لكن
انطلاقه إلى منصة الإطلاق بدأ الليلة الماضية  يمكننا أن
نرى هنا ، دعنا نحضر
مراسلة الفضاء كريستين فيشر بطيئة جدًا
ومثيرة للغاية هذه الخطوة إلى منصة الإطلاق ،
إنها بطيئة للغاية تستغرق طوال الليل
حوالي 10 ساعات.يمكن
لهذه المركبة التي تنقل الصاروخ إلى
منصة الإطلاق أن تقطع حوالي 0.8
ميل في الساعة فقط  لذلك قد لا يبدو
كثيرًا ولكن ما تراه هناك يدور
حول أنك تعرف أكثر من عقد من
تحقيق عدة مليارات من الدولارات أنها تصل الآن
إلى منصة الإطلاق
ولم نشاهد صاروخًا من طراز ناسا متجهًا
إلى القمر قادمًا  في منصة الإطلاق أه في
حوالي 50 عامًا ، هذا أمر تاريخي بشكل لا يصدق
ناسا يستهدف أه
إطلاق 29 أغسطس إذا سارت الأمور وفقًا
للخطة وأنت تعلم أن بريانا من الصعب
معرفة ما هو أكثر إثارة للإعجاب  فيما يتعلق
بالصاروخ نفسه أو الزاحف
الذي أوصل الصاروخ إلى منصة الإطلاق ،
تم بناء تلك الزواحف مرة أخرى في
الستينيات من القرن الماضي ، وهي مصممة لحمل صاروخ Saturn v
إلى منصة الإطلاق أثناء
برنامج أبولو ، الفرق على الرغم من
أنك تعرف في ذلك الوقت الولايات المتحدة  كان
في سباق فضاء مع روسيا للوصول
إلى القمر الآن المنافس الرئيسي لوكالة ناسا
في إعادة رواد الفضاء
إلى القمر هو الصين التي يحاولون فعل
نفس الشيء بالضبط ولذا يتساءل الكثير من
الناس ، ألا نفعل هذا
في الستينيات من القرن الماضي ، لم نكن نفعل هذا
في السبعينيات من القرن الماضي عندما أرسل ناسا رواد فضاء إلى
القمر ، الإجابة هي نعم ، لكن يتعين
عليهم فعل ذلك مرة أخرى لأن الصين الآن هي
التهديد الأساسي ، والآن ترى
صاروخ أرتميس هو  على بعد بوصات فقط
الآن من منصة الإطلاق أه وبعد
أسابيع قليلة فقط من الإطلاق ، آه في
29 أغسطس
ثمانية أميال في الساعة وهي ليست بهذه
السرعة ، فلا توجد ثمانية أميال في الساعة
أقل من ميل واحد في الساعة ولكن أعني
ذلك الصاروخ  بريانا تبلغ من العمر 34 عامًا
نفس ارتفاع
ناطحة سحاب من 34 طابقًا ، لذا فكر فقط في حجم
هذا الحجم ومقدار المال الموجود على
رأس هذا الزاحف ولهذا السبب
يجب أن تسير ببطء شديد